um ein gab ich an atrium minecraft
spielen wo man mit richtigen animationen
ich bin groß so freuen und damit
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
map vorstellungen minecraft und zwar
einer mario matt ihr habt mir unter die
letzten videos geschrieben die ich alle
so ein bisschen anders bearbeitet habe
also nicht den ganzen input einfach da
rein gepackt habe sondern wo ich dann
wirklich einfach mal so ein parkplatz
gesetz habe das ganze ein bisschen schön
zusammengeschnitten haben relativ
positives feedback und erwartet ja macht
das auch von anderen spielen wie
beispielsweise chorleiter kamen sehr oft
happy meals kam auch sehr oft als
vorschlag aber auch andere minecraft
maps und die könnten jetzt einfach unten
in die kommentare reihen spam und dann
werde ich eventuell die nächsten tage zu
happy meals goethe und bei anderen
sachen auch so kurze
zusammengeschnittene lustige videos
machen durch nur so die besten zehn rein
packe ich das gefällt dann lässt auf
jeden fall jetzt schon eine bewertung
dann auf jeden fall was ich vorher auch
immer sagen muss die map lässt sich auf
der version 14 wie 18 a spielen 42 18 b
eine von den beiden
die darauf folgenden versionen da
funktioniert das ganze bei mir nicht das
ist ein bisschen komisch ich weiß nicht
warum vielleicht ist bei euch anders
ihr seht auf jeden fall ein link zu dem
ursprünglichen video also wie die web
gemacht wurde et cetera und in der
beschreibung genau so wie ein
download-link
und da kann dir das ganze selbst und es
macht auf jeden fall sehr viel spaß und
deswegen will ich anfangen so ihr seht
schon ich bin hier in einer kleinen welt
wie das ganze am anfang gebaut ist und
das ganze so zusammengesetztes zeige ich
euch am ende des videos da will ich dann
einfach mal ein game ort bewegen
es kann sein dass bei euch ein paar
fehler auftreten dass sie beispielsweise
die hanns mattes umgekehrt das heißt
wenn ihr nach links mario ihr müsst in
die andere richtung laufen das ist halt
die ganze steuerung es umgekehrt und so
den sind wie gesagt ein paar fehler das
ist von einem ganz normalen menschen
gemacht worden nicht von mojang deswegen
finde ich sollte mir damit respekt auf
jeden fall dem die ab der person
begegnen weil es auf jeden fall sehr
sehr geil ist ich kann hier die
steuerung ist wenn ich nach vorne drücke
ich stehe quasi im 5 modus auf dieser
wand und da sind so unsichtbare blöcke
die mich davon abhalten dass ich nach
vorne gehe oder nach hinten
ich kann quasi nur noch links und rechts
gehen das ist ganz normale fünf wenn ich
einmal f5 drücken bin ich ist das quasi
umgedreht da muss man nochmal fünf
drücken als man hier und dann ist man
hier also mit 11 5 kann man das ganze um
visieren wenn man beispielsweise auf der
falschen seite
es gibt hier verschiedene blöcke es gibt
übrigens auch möglichst bald alles sehr
beschreibung
es gibt verschiedene blöcke da kann ich
mit space gegen springen dann bekomme
ich einen korn
das gleiche funktioniert auch hier wo
ich dann zum beispiel ein leben bekommen
das ist quasi das erste das ich glaube
das ist das erste mario level also daran
angelehnt weil da was auch zu dass es
einer waren dann hier zwei und obendrauf
noch was da oben drauf können nämlich
auch drauf springen nicht so aber so
dann kriegen wir noch was gehen wir in
die röhren rips die röhren können wir
nicht rein dann wird mir nach hinten
laufen also wenn ich nach unten drücken
da ist schon wieder ein kombi den
versuch jetzt auch eben zu töten dann
springe ich nämlich eben hier in dem
moment untersagt da ist auch toto und es
ist wirklich alles ja das sind ein paar
fehler die ich mal trug nein jetzt bin
ich wieder kleiner mario was mich auch
ganz geiles schaut mal mutig ist das
bringt zwar nichts dass ich ein extra
leben bekomme weil es nur ein
level ist was man spielen kann also es
gibt da nicht mehrere level aber es ist
halt auch dieser versteckte block sogar
das ist halt sehr sehr geil ich bin mal
kurz darüber da unten welche alt oder
kommt schon wieder so bomba tag habe ein
bisschen angst wenn ich immer nicht
dieser riesige mario been saidakova kann
ich auch hier oben drauf also es gibt
wirklich cool hier sind sogar wollten
meine damen und herren also es ist es
wunderschön sind wie gesagt hier alles
blöcke ihr könnt euch auch das ist
vielleicht ganz schön an alle die da
selbst mal gerne kreativ sind sehr sehr
schön es gibt glaube ich sogar
versteckte ich glaube dass wir so ein
versteckter ja genau hier ist es gibt
auch diese versteckten blogger also
wirklich angehen das erste mario level
jetzt der ausgebaut
wer cool wenn man diese blöcke auch
kaputt machen könnte achtung jetzt kommt
ihrem stern aus den nicht mario keller
damit kann ich halt alles darstellen
dass wir irgendwie den weg kommt so hier
sind dann wieder diese komischen ich
spiele das level erstmal zu einer danach
zeige ich euch warum das ganze sogar ist
ich finds halt sehr sehr geil dass das
ganze halt funktioniert durch das neue
update durch diesen snapshot also das
ist halt einfach dadurch hinzugefügt
werden dass man wie komme ich denn jetzt
da oben hin aber ich habe mir die idee
teile hier vorher kaputt gemacht scheiße
als ich den stern hatte es gibt mit dem
neuen update diese funktion dass man
beispielsweise sich in einen nicht in
einem blog verwandeln kann sondern dass
man quasi dieses diesen skin annehmen
kann der in einem resort spa zugeführt
würde also es gibt ja wie gesagt an
respekt für wenn man das nicht hat wenn
man ganz normal weiter hier sein eigenes
kind
aber das ist natürlich alles super meeuw
ich gehört hinzugefügt und jetzt sehen
wir auch schon das ende des levels wo
wir dann springen können und zeigt oder
ist da die fahne tutu und dann haben wir
das ganze level geschafft ich kann mal
ganz kurz in denen das war quasi mario
das war alles aber das ist auf jeden
fall heftigkeit so ich habe jetzt mal
ein game ort gesetzt ihr seht schon ich
bin hier in dem anderen f5 modus nicht
so drücken würde wäre die ganze
steuerung kommen komplett umgekehrt ich
würde ich drücke nach links und nach
rechts
deswegen wenn ihr den fehler hat einfach
ein 5 drücken und wie gesagt also wenn
ich ganz normal im game 80 bin kann ich
halt nicht runterfallen im gaylord 1
natürlich schon ich mal kurz mein
sichtfeld wieder auf normal auf 70 so
und zeigt euch jetzt das ganze hier
machen und zwar sind das wirklich alles
blöcke die im inventar vorhanden sind
beispielsweise das apple blog das ist so
ein komischer anderer blog hier kam was
das ist ja ja das auch noch und das sind
halt wirklich alles hier hier sind
granitblöcke magenta glas hier wieder
lapislazuli blog grünheid wieder hier
diese sind auch warte wo haben wir doch
die habe ich jetzt gerade zerstört news
blog also da steht wirklich hier alles
was das hier für blöcke sind und da
kommen wir jetzt auch schon mal dazu wo
ihr wahrscheinlich spawnen würdet ihr
das sind alles blöcke das ist hell
grünes gras beispielsweise hier würde
nämlich normalerweise spawnen also dann
nachher habe ich ja schon gesagt ihr
müsst dann fünf einmal dritten also ich
startet wahrscheinlich hier lest euch
das ganze durch setzt euch hin drückt er
fünf und dann seid ihr hier drin ihr
könnt dann ist quasi alles auf null
gesetzt ihr könnt
egal sporty halt immer wieder hier drauf
dass es quasi mal wieder von vorne
losgeht außerdem 8 game mode 1 und dann
seid ihr halt immun gegen die ganze
scheiße ihr könnt auch am besten in
euren einstellungen dieses eurer sicht
fällt so ein bisschen verändern dass wir
auf jeden fall auch ganz gut ja genau so
ist das hier halt alles aufgebaut die
ganze red cafe hier weiß ich jetzt nicht
wie das alles funktioniert guck mal
reichen holzbretter sehen nur ein
bisschen anders aus in diesen texture
pack
also es ist halt wirklich hier alles
sondern so ein bisschen gedauert
beispielsweise die diese biete diese
bauteile sind zum beispiel moment waren
wir dann karo murat sind aber es gibt
wirklich für alles objekt und dann
kommen jetzt auch schon in einer datei
die auch in der beschreibung findet und
zwar die halo spiel das jetzt zwar die
template welt ich mach mir mal kurz hier
in game und 1 kann hier jetzt
dementsprechend rumfliegen und ihr seht
schon so matthiesen energie ist ja
eigentlich nichts passiert das ist genau
die gleiche welt allerdings können wir
jetzt hier etwas bauen wir können jetzt
beispielsweise hier einfach mal so eine
mauer hinsetzen also irgendwie macht mal
so dass er mir vorhin schon gesehen so
eine konstruktion sondern setzt sich
oben vielleicht noch einen drauf und ich
das so und so da müsste die person
glaube ich hoch kommen und dann packt
jetzt einfach einmal sondern nur das
ganz ganz kleines oranges glas hier im
hintergrund so wir können das auch
theoretisch in den vordergrund setzen
das geht bei diesen anderen gras sachen
ihr müsst es allerdings im hintergrund
setzen damit das ganze so ein wenig
funktioniert also
papier nicht übereinander wird
vielleicht nicht sogar noch etwas hin so
damit die halt ein paar eigenschaften
mal sehen wie man das ganze da stehen
kam
ich hab grad türkisches glas gelesen ist
einfach türkises glas das schon jetzt
unseren tempel türkisches lokal am
besten geschafft habe ich dann noch in
potsdam der hinrich wird hierüber finden
sollte da ist ein fähnchen schaut mal
hier
das ist wunderschön sieht man auch voll
gut keine ahnung wie das mit dem
fähnchen hier funktionieren soll
irgendwie work das ganze hier gerade
nicht so da haben wir noch wissen dass
ihr achter sind auch noch so crazy
sachen die wir halten egal ich hätte das
ist mal etwas ganz kleines ich mir jetzt
mal kurz in game mode 0 führte mich
anzeigers ich mal ganz kurz hier im
moment hat man natürlich auch sein so
und wenn ich da ein bisschen rumlaufen
seht ihr dass das ganze ein bisschen
scheiße von mir gebaut wurde wenn ich
zum beispiel im moment nicht noch mal
kurz andersrum seht ihr ich bin noch
nicht so der kirche ich kann jetzt jeder
alles kaputtmachen moment das anders das
kommt doch gar nicht von mir
tt.com formierten falsches pont moment
sei also ihr seht das ist ein bisschen
scheiße gebaut von mir tut mir leid tue
mir sorry
man kann die dann allerdings im oktober
ich habe hier nur diese blöcke gemacht
wird lokal auf ja wenn man sich damit
länger beschäftigt ihr seht auf jeden
fall der sinn funktioniert man kann sich
hier verschiedene dinge dann auf jeden
fall zusammen basteln und dann bin ich
hier dann irgendwann im ziel und dann
sind hier auch noch sachen und dann kann
ich mich wieder in game 1 machen und
wenn ihr dann ganz kreativ seid könnt
ihr dann ganz viele andere sachen da
noch hin bauen wie beispielsweise
momentan haben wir denn diese ein blöcke
das ist hier nicht noch irgendwo was da
haben wir den das obst dass das und das
das ist nämlich auch ganz interessant
und zwar wenn ich hierzu blöcke habe so
kann ich hier quasi so einen dran setzen
möchte wieder weg setzt ja so einen
richter zum ball hin setzte wenn da mal
laufen würde
dadurch dass ich hier vorher den hierhin
gepackt habe und hier quasi an das
hierhin packe dann ist der grund war
immer dazwischen und ist quasi nicht
hier so damit er quasi da abgelenkt und
geht dann da wieder zurück der bewegt
sich nur irgendwie nicht also der bewegt
sich wenn ich dann spiele rips jetzt
habe ich die transzendenz hier weg
gemacht
er bewegt sich dann halt nur zwischen
diesem bereich dass es ganz gut damit
man die dann eins einkehren kann damit
die nicht einfach über die ganzen
mitlaufen durch alle blöcke durchgehend
habe ich würde sagen dass war das ganze
um das selbst auszuprobieren könnt ihr
euch das einfach selbst runterladen ich
finds auf jeden fall eine richtig
richtig geile map daumen hoch an den
entwickler lassen auf jeden fall einen
schönen gruß von mir da ich würde sagen
es euch gefallen hat und ihr mehr von
solchen sachen wollt dann schreibt sie
meine kommentare oder dass es zeigt dass
mit einer bewertung kann ich sagen ich
gehe etwas aufnehmen mit zwei anderen
leuten was auch ganz cool wird dieses
projekt das mir die tage sehen